okay okay okay this
is going to piss some people off some of
you are going to turn your backs on me
forever
sorry to see you go i have to tell you
this reality i have not
shampooed my hair for five years and yet
those five years have been
some of the best five years of my hair's
life no more itching
no more oily hair no more dandruff
flakes
just normal hair that does weird stuff
sometimes
but is generally happy let me explain
go ahead take a good look i know
everyone's already doing it anyway look
at my hair i've never felt so conscious
about my hair because i'm talking about
it
okay so five years ago i realized that i
was in
a cycle the cycle looked like this my
head
which produces natural protective oils
would be washed with shampoo
shampoo is just a chemical that attaches
to these oils
on your scalp and then when you wash
that shampoo out the oils are attached
to them and they
leave gritting your head of oils the
shampoo also cleans off any pollen or
dust that's caught in your hair so my
hair was now
clean very clean oh yeah and this guy
isn't me this is just a stock footage
representation of me
five years ago anyway then goes in the
conditioner which coats your hair with
silicone material that makes it shine
and restores all of that shine that was
lost from stripping away
all of those oils man i haven't used
conditioner in a very long time but i do
remember that it makes your hair
feel like silky butter
silky butter is that even a thing okay
so you strip away the oils
you coat it with this shiny silky
conditioner and then my hair would end
up just being
sort of like a fluff ball in order to
style it i would put in some product
like some
fancy pomade i bought at some fancy
barber in chicago
this pomade is made of wait for it
oil it is an oil based product i'm
putting oil
back in my hair after i just stripped it
all out meanwhile my scalp is like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa dude you just
stripped away all this protective oil
that we make to protect your scalp
wtf and so it fires up its natural oil
making machine
to produce more oil for your hair so now
you have double oil you've got the
pomade and the natural oils so now
by the end of the day you start to feel
like your hair is super
oily and greasy and you have all these
messages about
dirty hair being greasy and oily hey you
have got creasy hair though bro oh come
on man
so what's the cure for this oily greasy
dirty hair
shampoo deep cleansing shampoo it helps
take away the excess dirt and oils that
can be inside your hair right i reckon
we should give it a go and get washed up
let's do it
and the whole cycle starts over again in
my mid-20s i also started to realize
that my scalp was starting to become
like itchy
and flaky which is like so embarrassing
so uncomfortable and yet luckily out
there in the world there is a cure for
this
the problem of flaking dandruff can be
solved
with just regular use of procter
gamble's new wonder shampoo
head and shoulders okay listen just a
quick moment
to make it clear that this cycle is
my hair experience which is based on not
only my
physiology and genetics but also on
my standards and relationship to society
and what society tells me to do with my
hair so just to get this out of the way
i'm not here to preach what's right for
your scalp
i'm simply telling you what's right for
my scalp
in fact there's this whole movement sort
of a political movement around
shampoo and not shampooing it's called
no poo which is a very
unfortunate name for this movement i'm
not a part of that movement i'm not
pushing that this isn't political for me
i just want to tell you a story about
the journey of my hair using
a little bit of history and data and
research
and again most importantly my own
experience of five years of not
shampooing my hair okay so let's dive in
let's get some context here human beings
used to not wash their hair very much at
all it was only by the 1970s when
ads targeted mainly towards white women
would come out saying that
you needed to wash your hair every
single day
and that the dirt in your hair was like
weighing it down
and weigh hair down like this and that
in order to prevent this weighing
down and to get body you would have to
use this product
this also started a whole new set of
messaging around greasy hair
dirty hair which even saying it is like
repulsive so demonizing the idea of
greasy hair
and pushing this daily shampoo regimen
was seen as the only way to
fight back against this greasy hair
epidemic
today americans wash their hair
around five of the seven days of the
week by the way that's about double
how much they wash their hair on average
in spain and italy
and it's way more than the once a month
americans used to wash their hair
in the 30s so let me tell you the story
of how this all went down
because i didn't like grow up as a
non-shampooer five years ago
i had bought this really expensive fancy
tea tree oil based
dandruff shampoo because i had so much
itchiness and flakiness everywhere
i was so tired of that and i was so
embarrassed by it so i was diligent
i would wash my hair with this tea tree
oil
shampoo every day the marketing on this
told me that i shouldn't use any other
shampoos that all the other shampoos
were the devil and that this was the
only thing i could use to treat my
dandruff i ran out of this shampoo while
we were on like a trip
so i couldn't order it and i was just
like okay when i get back i'll order the
shampoo and i'll get back onto it and it
like
took a while we were on some long trip i
get back i forget to order the shampoo
i was getting worried about this but
soon after like three weeks
of this sort of fear of using other
shampoos i noticed that the itching
started going away
and that the greasy hair feel started to
actually level
out it was actually okay and i was
secretly like oh and probably i probably
just got used to it or something but the
key moment happened
when i went in to get a haircut having
not washed my hair with
shampoo for like a month i was actually
really nervous and conscious of what the
barber was gonna say to me
and he didn't say anything so i asked
him i was like hey how does
my hair and scalp look to you and he was
like looks good it's a little dry
but overall pretty healthy and that was
the moment for me i was like wait
what this guy who sees like dozens of
scalps
every day dozens of scalps that's
actually really gross
like dozens of scallops i'm just not
never gonna say that again this guy sees
a lot of scallops every day
and he had like blessed my unshampooed
scalp
and was like you're actually okay now
let me just remind you that i've told
some of my close friends this story
before and they have tried it and it
hasn't worked for them i'm not saying
that this
exact thing is going to work for you the
reason i am making this video
because i want us to have reasons to be
skeptical of all the messages that we
get
fed around this topic nourishing damaged
hair back to healthy life
regular washing is the only way that you
can get rid of that excess oil i feel no
grease
a few years ago i read this kind of
obnoxious business book
that said that the best way to market a
product is to create
a psychological trigger that makes
people need
your product the example used in the
book was this toothpaste
in like the 50s or 60s where the ad for
this toothpaste
called attention to this quote dangerous
coding that
robs the teeth of their whiteness like
this film coding that's like on your
teeth
every time you eat and it's like
dangerous and bad and socially
unacceptable
turns out that this dangerous film on
your teeth is a harmless residue from
food consumption
and toothpaste doesn't remove it any
better than eating an apple
so yes you should totally brush your
teeth but not because there's this
dangerous residue
and now i can't unfeel it the
psychological trigger is baked in i
can't not feel it and i feel
judged because i maybe have this
dangerous coding this same dynamic
happens today
with the 100 billion hair care industry
they push all sorts of scary ideas about
dirty things lurking in your hair that
only their product can fix
and they get very rich because of it
telling you that you have grease in your
hair makes you
feel dirty psychologically and what it
does is it turns these naturally
occurring
lipids or fats in your hair which are
totally protective and naturally
occurring
into this gross feeling dangerous thing
and more and more these commercials have
these like fancy
3d diagrams to make it feel totally
legit
and medical there are medical things
here like dandruff is a real
skin disorder that's something that has
real symptoms and should be treated
in a real medical way by a professional
not by a commercial with a fake doctor
showing you 3d diagrams to sell
a product and no this lady is not a
legit doctor she's an actor while we're
on the point of dandruff and itchy
scalps let it be known that dry scalp
which is not a skin disorder
literally means that your you don't have
enough hydration in your scalp is not
dandruff
but he's scratching his head could be
dandruff and yet
they share effectively the same symptoms
itchy flaky but
dry scalp unlike dandruff is caused in
part by
wait for it shampooing too much
drying out your scalp by stripping it of
its natural hydrating oils
this was my problem in my 20s i didn't
have dandruff
i thought i had dandruff because i was
shampooing my hair too much and it was
drying out my scalp and making it dry
and flaky
all of this gets conflated when
corporations present their
advertisements as
legit science that's meant to help you
feel better
but let's just quickly say it like it is
the only thing they're doing
is trying to sell you a product to make
sure that you feel like you need it as
much as possible
where this becomes totally below the
belt in my view is when these
commercials tell the story of how you
will be
socially ostracized if you don't use
their product
use head and shoulders every day and
this gets to the last point i want to
make here and potentially the biggest
reason why i made this video i don't
care about you shampooing your hair you
probably should i you need to just
determine that on your own
but let us just recognize that we are
social animals we live
and die by what others think of us we
strive
to be accepted by the group at any cost
and my big fear here is that
we have given the power of what we need
to do to be accepted
to these big corporations these giant
machines
who use this psychological dynamic to
sell us more of their stuff
they have successfully turned hair into
a discussion
of hygiene and cleanliness and now we
talk about this
almost as a form of epidemiology
cleanliness and hygiene
turns into an issue of health and safety
which let's be honest
brushing your teeth or washing your
hands that that
stuff is there to stop us from spreading
diseases i haven't washed my hair in
five years and there's not some virus
that's
to pop off my head and go infect my
family
that's a very strange image head virus
there are real skin disorders having to
do with the scalp those should be
treated seriously
but my sense is that we've conflated
that we're not talking about health and
disease prevention
a lot of the time we're talking about
beauty and self-perception
that's not epidemiology that's personal
psychology
personal self-esteem and societal
standards
that feeling of being dirty or greasy
who determined that feeling who set the
parameters for that feeling
it's not nature it's not epidemiology if
you had been born 50 years ago you
wouldn't have that same feeling of being
greasy it's not natural
and even in 2021 if you were born in
spain you would less likely
have that feeling of just being dirty
that drives you to consume more and more
of these products
which helps you build the nearly 100
billion dollar hair care industry
a huge portion of which is owned by just
three companies l'oreal procter campbell
and unilever which find a million ways
to feel like
you are dirty you are undesirable and if
you don't use their product you will be
ostracized from society
just look at these commercials what's
wrong take over your head
no wait it's it's dry try head and
shoulders dry skull care these companies
have cracked the code on what
drives us and it's fear and a desire to
be accepted
and this is just with hair this is with
a million of these products
that tell us that we're inferior and if
i'm saying this
as a man in this society it is a
thousand times worse
for women so am i here telling you not
to shampoo your hair
no do whatever you want you have a
totally different hair experience than i
do
i'm sure stopping cold turkey like i did
probably isn't the right choice for you
all i'm asking you is to scrutinize
your standards and who is in control of
the narrative
of what clean even means okay
that's that speaking of the psychology
of self-esteem
in the 21st century i want to tell you
about the sponsor of today's video
which is better help it's an online tool
that allows you to connect
with a professional trained counselor so
that you can have therapy but do it
remotely
i've been in therapy for the past year
and a half and for the majority of that
it's been
remote i haven't been sitting in the
therapist's office and i can't stress
enough how important it has been for me
my understanding of myself and my
well-being as
a person and as a husband and as a
father and as a brother and as all the
roles that i play in my life
therapy has been amazing better help is
not a crisis line
it is not a self-help scheme it is a
platform for
finding a counselor and starting therapy
so that you can
start to make strides in your mental
health my favorite part about betterhelp
is that it makes it
free and easy to change your counselors
it often takes a while to find the right
therapist for your life
and with betterhelp you have a ton of
options as well as the ability to
if you don't find a good fit at first or
second or third you can keep trying
until you find the right counselor for
you
better help is more affordable than
traditional counseling which can be
fairly expensive and there is financial
aid
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life out today
and i am a major proponent of therapy as
a an ongoing practice i wish it was more
accessible
better help is making it so so go to
betterhelp.com
johnny harris that's better h-e-l-p-com
johnny harris and join the over 1
million people who are
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
clicking that link helps support this
channel but it also gives you 10 off
your first
month of therapy thank you better help
for sponsoring this video thank you all
for watching
thank you patrons for your ongoing
support i hope some of you stick around
even though i don't wash my hair
all the time okay see ya